welcome back are you looking for a snack
that tastes great and is healthy yes
always no further than our sponsors
American pistachio Grocers Dana Devon
has more
hi everyone I'm Dana Devin with some
important news coming out of Cornell
University Research a new study reveals
pistachios have greater levels of
antioxidants than previously understood
in fact pistachios are among the highest
when compared to other common foods
known for their antioxidant capacity
such as blueberries pomegranates
cherries and beets we studied the health
benefit of the pistachio
phytochemical profile
antioxidant activity and the nutrients
of Pistachio Pistachio are higher very
high this statue is one of the common
nuts consumed by consumers that's why we
study the health benefit of pistachios
foreign
nutrition consultant Dr Mike Roussel
explains how this most recent study is a
game changer for health conscious
consumers when people think of high
antioxidant Foods they think of foods
like berries blueberries cherries
pomegranates and red wine they don't
think of nuts and this new research
shows that pistachios are actually a
really high and Powerful source of
antioxidants in the diet antioxidant on
natural compound in pistachios or other
plant-based food
with the capability to quench the free
radical most people know that
antioxidants are beneficial to health
but many don't know how antioxidants
work within the body antioxidants are a
really popular term but people probably
don't know other than that they're good
for them what they actually do
I think of antioxidants as the good guys
for our health so our body needs them to
help fight things called free radicals
now our body generates and creates free
radicals from all kinds of things such
as pollution sunlight but even just
stress in our lives or exercise
and when there's too much and too many
free radicals that can cause problems
with our health
nutrients high quality protein and also
hiring fiber hiring the karate noise
vitamin E and this should be the parts
of the house detachary pattern in
addition to being high in antioxidants
pistachios contain six grams of complete
protein which means it contains all the
essential components from a protein
perspective that is what our body needs
something you generally only find in
animal proteins one of the things that I
think is great about pistachios is they
contain a variety of healthful nutrients
so like what we call a nutrient package
and what this research shows is that
when you take that whole food pistachio
and consume it that it has even more
benefits experts say pistachios are
bursting with protein and the fiber
minerals and unsaturated fat that can
help keep your blood sugar blood
pressure and cholesterol in check and
now we know pistachios are an
antioxidant Powerhouse for more
information about the benefits of
pistachios or the Cornell study go to
americanpistachios.org in Los Angeles
I'm Dana Devon